big little lies season 2 it has happened
it's happening happening did you think
it would no I didn't see it coming I
really didn't I mean you know when you
sign on to something that they say is it
one season that you believe here we are
here we are with Meryl we are with here
we are with Marilyn I exactly it yes you
know you you you got to work with her
what was it like just just say hello
Dori
it was everything I wanted to be it more
you know you I idolized her of course
but getting to actually know her as a
human being was even better than I could
imagine and her love for storytelling
and her love for the craft and it's
inspiring to see someone who's been
doing it for so long and so well still
hungry not to do more won by the way she
told me her love for wine she said enjoy
well we all we all love we all love our
wine and so you got its big little it is
the wine that finds us you know
last question your character you know
she struggled she has a bigger story
this season what can we expect and does
she keep the secret I don't want to say
the second thing that's I'll get in
trouble
I didn't expect you to be a Oh a nice
try and I strike we can expect a little
more humanity from her I think in season
one bonnie is kind of painted as this
perfect person and
you know her attraction to health and
meditation all of that is running from
something there's a reason that that's
something she's attracted to so we get
to see a little bit of more perfume
inside of this season I heard an Emmys
buzz for you already girl I'm nacho oh
really yes
that's called am truly happy to be here
I didn't mean it
happy to work with Muriel happy to be
here I smelled nominees for all of you
if I may god I mean that would be cool
and also I think it's like well I'm sure
it is the screen was amazing you call it
thank you thank you
[Music]